do you love her or do you love the idea
of her I don't know man I just don't
know
I gotta make an example out of him
should I just fire him can you actually
fire people to be honest I don't know
but maybe I could just yell at him in
front of people
well I can't really imagine you yelling
at anyone well I yell you've heard me
yeah oh okay I've heard you exclaim like
the time you said hey look we parked
over here oh that was apple picking day
there's no need to yell that day you
know I was just excited to find the car
perfect end to a perfect day
well
you'll figure it out
hey Ryan how's it going
here's the thing
um I've tried like five different ways
in my head and oh got one
um I'm such a perfectionist that I'd
kind of rather not do it at all than do
a crappy version simple data entry
though so there's really only one way to
do it sounds like you have a really
specific vision for it do you want to
maybe just take a look at it you know
what what I think I know the problem
great I think you seem distracted yep
that is the problem and you know what I
came up with something I think it's
really going to help well I'm glad
you're finally being proactive Jim I am
too let me show you
I think this is really going to help you
just hold up here one second
hey guys just a quick announcement if I
could have everyone's attention
you needed a place where you could
concentrate and not be bothered by
bothering people okay let me show you
what I mean
your new office how great is that right
for a job well done well not done I will
uh I will do my work right now I will
stay late tonight right
um I'm very sorry about everything
you're a good kid you know when it gets
bigger once you're in there enjoy it
is there internet
okay Ryan's the temp what does he do at
night
I guess we just have to wait until night
and see
oh
or maybe not
oh
how romantic is this super romantic
you see a clue or yeah did you not see
him oh my gosh thanks
ah oh hey hey no time to chat
I'm just looking for Ryan so he's not
here hey you're looking for me oh yeah
we were we were just gonna say hi so hey
no you weren't no we weren't you wanted
to have sex in my office nope definitely
not it's it's it's cool just um try to
put everything back where you found it
uh text me when you're finished up I'll
be out here hey you don't have to
that was so embarrassing I'm gonna die
that was really rough
because they're a front runner you know
what they all just sort of blend
together after a while
well there must be someone who stands
out no not at all in fact I'm not even
taking it seriously I think at the end
of the day I'm just gonna pick a name
out of that well
what the hell you will I worked for the
last boss for 15 years according to my
doctor I don't have another 15 years if
I want to keep up the same dietary and
sexual lifestyle which I intend to oh no
Stanley you'll live forever my next boss
will be my last boss he'll be at my
funeral so I would appreciate it if you
would take this seriously
you pick a crappy boss you're
responsible for my crappy life okay
everybody I was just making a joke I am
taking it seriously I promise are you
a little of ice take a day off from the
whole gym stick
try caring about something
you might like how it feels
James
Michael how's it going bro good good bro
hey thanks so much for having my back
out there always rub your back
so any ideas on how we can get over this
nine-day hump here I am nothing but
ideas the thing is they all require
money nine days though that's like look
I know I've tapped to you so hard yes
you have tapped this hard
oh you are funny Michael you people
people don't give you enough credit
maybe I could take a second mortgage on
my condo well a lot of people are doing
that and there don't seem to be any
consequences and they say the rates have
never been lower
so you would think that's a good idea
for me to do think about this you and me
on a private plane flown by our Private
Pilot eating our private meal cooked by
our private Chef right we never even
have dinner now so we totally should
tonight
I gotta work on this all right what am I
saying okay rain check yeah
a video chat I Skype I text I tweet I
phone I woof woof is the site that I'm
launching to be the last word in social
networking for just 12.99 a month wolf
links up all your communication portals
so you are always Within Reach it's part
of the dog pack as I call it but look
why tell you when I can show you I just
sent myself a woof
Ryan you have a wolf online one thank
you Aaron
woof